Continuous integration is the idea
that you're always making sure your
code can be integrated with
the remote repository..
So across a team,
you'll always have a stable build.
Now we won't go into detail on CI,
as much of it is already covered
in the dev ops udacity course.
But a key lesson here is that CI in
the cloud provides a great place for
your time intensive tasks.
In particular, your unit tests.
A cloud solution like Jenkins will watch
the commits going into your repository
and trigger any terminal
commands you feed it.
So if you take the Gulp test task that
we've just created and hook it up in
the cloud, it means that the test
suite will run after every commit.
But on a completely different computer,
letting you go in coding.
If one of these tests now fails,
you've got a email and
can fix it in your next commit.
We'll leave our task as is for
now, but do go and
check out the dev ops Udacity course
when you're finished with ours.